CONTAINING ANTI-SEMITIC THEMES.
THIS PAST WEEKEND HE ATTEMPTED
TO EXPLAIN THAT.
>> I AM IN A UNIQUE POSITION TO
HAVE A LEVEL OF INFLUENCE ON MY
COMMUNITY, AND WHAT I POST DOES
NOT MEAN THAT I SUPPORT
EVERYTHING BEING SAID OR
EVERYTHING THAT IS BEING DONE OR
I'M CAMPAIGNING FOR ANYTHING.
ALL I DO IS POST THINGS FOR MY
PEOPLE AND MY COMMUNITY AND
THOSE IT IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
IMPACT.
ANYBODY ELSE THAT HAS CRITICISM
OBVIOUSLY IT WASN'T MEANT FOR
THEM.
I AM NO DIFFERENT THAN THE NEXT
HUMAN BEING SO DON'T TREAT ME
DIFFERENT.
YOU GUYS COME IN HERE AND MAKE
UP THIS POWERFUL INFLUENCE I
HAVE OVER THE TOP OF THE
ADULTERY OF OH, YOU CANNOT POST
THAT.
WHY NOT?
>> WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO PROMOTE
SOMETHING ALEX JONES SAID?
>> THAT WAS A FEW WEEKS AGO.
I DO NOT STAND WITH ALEX JONES'
POSITION, NARRATIVE.
THE COURT CASE HE HAD WITH SANDY
HOOK OR ANY OF THE KIDS THAT
FELT LIKE THEY HAD TO RELIVE
TRAUMA OR THE PARENTS THAT HAD
TO RELIVE TRAUMA OR TO BE
DISMISSIVE TO ALL THE LIVES THAT
WERE LOST DURING THAT TRAGIC
EVENT.
MY POST WAS A POST FROM ALEX
JONES THAT HE DID IN THE EARLY
'90s OR LATE '90s ABOUT SECRET
SOCIETIES IN AMERICA, OF A CULT,
AND IT IS TRUE.
SO I WASN'T IDENTIFYING WITH
ANYTHING BEING A CAMPAIGNIST FOR
ALEX JONES OR ANYTHING.
I WAS JUST THERE TO POST.
AND IT'S FUNNY, ACTUALLY
HILARIOUS BECAUSE OUT OF ALL OF
THE THINGS I POSTED THAT DAY
THAT WAS THE ONE EVERYONE CHOSE
TO SEE.
IT JUST GOES BACK TO THE WAY OUR
WORLD IS AND WORKS.
I'M NOT HERE TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
IT.
I JUST EXIST.
>> TO FOLLOW UP ON THE PROMOTION
OF THE MOVIE AND THE BOOK --
>> CAN YOU PLEASE STOP CALLING
IT A PROMOTION?
WHAT AM I PROMOTING?
>> YOU PUT IT OUT ON YOUR
PLATFORM.
>> I'M PROMOTING IT?
DO YOU SEE ME DOING --
>> BY PUTTING IT OUT THERE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SAY YOU ARE
PROMOTING
>> I PUT IT OUT THERE JUST LIKE
YOU PUT THINGS OUT THERE.
>> YEAH BUT I --
>> YOU PUT THINGS OUT FOR A
LIVING RIGHT?
GREAT.
SO LET'S MOVE ON.
>> FILLED WITH ANTI-SEMITIC
STUFF --
>> DON'T DE HUMANIZE ME.
I AM FREE TO POST WHATEVER I
WANT SO SAY THAT AND SHUT IT
DOWN AND MOVE TO THE NEXT
QUESTION.
>> KYRIE, YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
>> I DON'T HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
ANYTHING FROM YOU.
NOTHING.
MOVE ON.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> BY POSTING WHAT YOU DID --
ANYBODY CAN LOOK AT IT AND
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY --
>> YOU GUYS HAVE ANY MORE
QUESTIONS?
THIS IS GOING TO BE A CLIP HE IS
GOING TO MARVEL AT.
ANY MORE QUESTIONS?
>> BUT YOU'RE NOT ANSWERING THE
QUESTION.
>> OH, MY GOD.
MAKE ANOTHER INSTAGRAM CLIP SO
WE CAN BE FAMOUS AGAIN.
NEXT QUESTION.
>> THAT EXCHANGE WITH NICK
PURREDEL THE OTHER NIGHT AFTER
THE GAME.
LOOK, IF HE -- HE KEEPS MAKING A
BIG THING OUT OF THE WORD
PROMOTION.
THAT IS PROMOTION, IF ON YOUR
SOCIAL MEDIA YOU SAY BOOM HERE
IS A LINK TO THIS, THAT TELLS
ME, HEY, YOU SHOULD WATCH THIS.
CORRECT?
HE HAS SOMETHING MILLION
INSTAGRAM FOLLOWERS AND ANOTHER
5 MILLION OR SO ON TWITTER.
YOU'RE ALL OVER SOCIAL MEDIA.
DO YOU EVER PUT SOMETHING OUT
THAT DOES NOT REPRESENT WHAT YOU
FEEL?
>> I WAS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
FIRST GUYS ON TWITTER.
WHEN I REALIZED THE POWER IT HAD
I KNEW I HAD TO BE VERY
RESPONSIBLE.
FOLLOWERS, PLATFORM, WHATEVER
YOU CALL IT I KNEW I HAD TO BE
RESPONSIBLE.
I TRY TO MAKE PEOPLE HAPPY AND
SMILE.
60% TO MAKE YOU LAUGH, 30% TO
INSPIRE YOU, AND 10% WHATEVER
I'M SELLING I'M SELLING.
YOU HAVE TO BE AWARE OF WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
AND BE AWARE THAT SOMETIMES WHEN
YOU PUT STUFF OUT NOT EVERYBODY
IS GOING TO LIKE IT.
SOME PEOPLE ARE CONSCIOUS SOME
PEOPLE ARE NOT.
I CAN TELL HE IS NOT CONSCIOUS
AND DOESN'T REALLY CARE WHAT'S
GOING ON.
BUT I KNOW THAT THE GAME THAT WE
USED TO LOVE AND PROMOTE BRINGS
PEOPLE TOGETHER.
IT HURTS ME SOMETIMES WHEN WE
HAVE TO SIT UP HERE AND TALK
ABOUT STUFF THAT DIVIDES THE
GAME.
WE GOT TO ANSWER FOR WHAT THIS
IDIOT HAS DONE.
YOU KNOW, I STAND FOR EQUALITY
OF ALL PEOPLE.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN LIKE THAT.
DON'T MATTER YOUR RELIGION OR
WHERE YOU'RE FROM.
I CAN SAY SHALOM, THAT'S HOW I
WAS RAISED.
I DON'T WANT TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
FOR WHAT HE HAS DONE.
LOOKING AT ME IT IS MY JOB TO
MAKE PEOPLE HAPPY.
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR HIM OR ANSWER
FOR WHAT HE IS DOING.
IT IS OBVIOUS BY HIS ANSWERS AND
THE WAY HE ANSWERED HE DOESN'T
REALLY CARE.
>> CHUCK?
>> I THINK THE NBA DROPPED THE
BALL.
>> IN WHAT WAY?
>> I THINK HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SUSPENDED.
I THINK ADAM SHOULD HAVE
SUSPENDED HIM.
FIRST OF ALL ADAM IS JEWISH.
YOU CAN'T TAKE MY $40 MILLION
THEN INSULT MY RELIGION.
YOU'RE GOING TO INSULT ME YOU
HAVE THE RIGHT BUT I HAVE THE
RIGHT TO SAY NO.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO TAKE MY
$40 MILLION AND INSULT MY
RELIGION.
I THINK THE NBA MADE A MISTAKE.
WE HAVE SUSPENDED PEOPLE AND
FINED PEOPLE WHO HAVE MADE
HOMOPHOBIC SLURS.
THAT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
I THINK IF YOU INSULT THE BLACK
COMMUNITY YOU SHOULD BE
SUSPENDED OR FINED HEAVILY.
THEY DID THE SAME THING TO THE
KID IN MINNESOTA WHEN HE MADE
THE GAY SLUR.
YOU SHOULD GET SUSPENDED OR
FINED.
I THINK HIM ACKNOWLEDGING THE
ALEX JONES THING SHOULD,
SOMETHING SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED
WITH THAT, TOO.
THAT DUDE IS CRAZY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE, WE AIN'T
TALKING ABOUT THAT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS IDIOT.
IF I SAY, HEY, I'M AGREEING WITH
THIS, MOVING THIS BOOK OR
WHATEVER, I AM AGREEING WITH IT.
FIRST OF ALL, YOU KNOW I DON'T
DO ANY SOCIAL MEDIA BUT WHEN
YOU'RE SOMEBODY AT GREAT AT
BASKETBALL AS HIM PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO LISTEN TO WHAT YOU SAY.
THEN THERE ARE FRINGE PEOPLE OUT
THERE -- LIKE I SAY, I BLAME THE
NBA.
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN SUSPENDED.
>> CONVERSATIONS ARE CONTINUING
WITH THE BROOKLYN NETS.
>> TOO LATE NOW.
>> THEY'RE ALSO LOOKING AT,
LOOK, HOW DO WE MOVE FORWARD.
>> IT'S TOO LATE NOW.
>> NO IT'S NOT TOO LATE TO SAY
HOW DO WE PREVENT THIS.
>> I WANT TO SAY THIS.
THE REASON IT'S TOO LATE, THE
NBA HAS GIVEN IN TO PEER
PRESSURE.
IF ONE OF OUR PLAYERS DO
SOMETHING THEY HAVE THE RIGHT,
THE TEAM, OR THE LEAGUE HAS TO
DO SOMETHING IMMEDIATELY.
IF YOU JUST GIVE IN TO PEER
PRESSURE, THAT'S THE PROBLEM I
HAVE.
THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN HANDLED
ALREADY.
>> KENNY, GO AHEAD.
>> FIRSTLY, IF WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE WHAT HE SAYS ON A TWITTER
WE HAVE TO TAKE EVERYTHING HE
SAYS.
SO IF I'M GOING TO TAKE
EVERYTHING HE SAYS I'M GOING TO
BELIEVE HE DOESN'T SUPPORT OR
ANY OF THE VIEWS OR PROMOTE THE
VIEWS.
HE SAID IT RIGHT IN MY FACE.
I HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT.
SO I WILL BELIEVE THAT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THIS WORLD
WHO HAVE DONE -- IN THEIR ART
HAVE DONE GREAT THINGS THAT HAVE
SAID CRAZY THINGS THAT WE STILL
LISTEN TO THEIR MUSIC.
WE WALK BY THEIR PAINTINGS.
WE DO THEIR THINGS.
YOU MIGHT TAKE AN EXCERPT AND
SAY I BELIEVE IN THIS.
OKAY.
I'LL TAKE THAT AS IT MAY FROM
KYRIE IRVING.
I ALSO BELIEVE THE REPORTER HAD
A RIGHT TO ASK THE QUESTION.
>> SURE.
>> THAT'S IT.
THAT'S REALLY WHERE THE ARGUMENT
BECAME.
YOU DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO ASK ME
THAT QUESTION.
I DO BELIEVE THAT.
AND BASED ON THIS FOR KYRIE, HE
HAS PUT HIMSELF AS HE SAYS I'M
THE VOICE FOR SOME OF THE
SPEECHLESS.
DURING THE COVID.
NOW HE HAS TRANSCENDED FROM
BASKETBALL AND BECAME AN
ACTIVIST POLITICALLY.
SO YOU WILL ASK HIM THAT
QUESTION BASED ON SOME THINGS
THAT YOU MAY READ.
I HAVE TO BELIEVE HIM ALSO WHEN
HE TELLS ME, THAT IS IF I'M
GOING TO BELIEVE PARTS OF IT I
HAVE TO BELIEVE THE TOTALITY.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I JUST THINK KYRIE IS JUST PART
OF THIS.
I JUST THINK WE'VE LOST OUR WAY.
I THINK IN THIS COUNTRY WE'VE
LOST OUR WAY.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE FORGOTTEN
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO PUT THE
THOUGHT PROCESS INTO, IF I PUT
THIS OUT THERE, WHO AM I GOING
TO HURT?
AND THEY HAVEN'T -- THEY'RE
GIVING NO THOUGHT TO THAT.
WHERE IS CIVILITY THESE DAYS?
WHERIS EMP